what's the one thing that's worse than
Tai Lopez well check the sidebar and you
will find a gaggle of other influencers
that are also willing to take your money
with a lot of promises to make you rich
and no real results there's not much
that competes with Tai Lopez's scamming
people who are broke and are looking for
a way to make money but Mike vestal
takes it to another level and he does
this by having none of none of the
skills I mean say what you want about
Tai Lopez he built the Empire he's was
one of the oh geez he had that viral
marketing campaign Mike vestal is none
of that he's not an original he's a
copycat if you go to his website and I
can't believe I'm about to take you
there Mike Vestal com
oh I'm gonna push this over here Mike
vestal and you go cuz he wrote a book
he's 20 years old and he decided what a
great idea let me write a book on how to
be successful what's this
health wealth love and happiness hmm
that sounds that sounds awful familiar
health wealth happiness love living the
good life that's another someone someone
else's catchphrase I wanted to find the
good life he basically took Tai loaf has
his idea and said I'm just gonna copy
everything this guy does and do it worse
the thing that I hate about these
youtubers the most this new wave of
influencers and people who are trying to
be mentorship coaches is you can't be a
mentorship coach if you haven't been
through anything and if you haven't
built anything this is like the problem
with Tai Lopez in the first place
is nobody knows what he did before he
was Tai Lopez the meme but it's a bigger
problem with these kids that couldn't
have had businesses before they started
was what are essentially coaching
businesses so straight out the gate they
become coaches it doesn't even make any
sense so like look at the first part of
this video okay
NORs a life where he is forced to evolve
and no it's not just by buying a bunch
of polos so in today's video we're gonna
talk about the four stages wait for
station the fourth before she didn't get
even thought all these videos right this
guy has not evolved because he's he's
not even really an entrepreneur he just
built some he just made up some coaching
class and said he's gonna scale you six
to seven figures this guy hasn't even
made six to seven figures okay let's see
what this is all about
Mike Vestal CEO and founder of a hundred
K tribe where we help coaches culture it
so what is he's a coach to be a coach to
coaches like this is what doesn't make
sense to me about this whole tile Lopez
thing and all this little team that they
have a bunch of Tai Lopez's do these
people compete with each other I assume
they do they're all offering master
classes and what do you teach your kit
your students to do this guy's a title
at Lopez student I guess Tai Lopez
taught him to make master classes to
compete with Tai Lopez's master classes
and is Mike the steel teaching people to
create master classes to I mean all of
these guys have these these just paid
programs and by the way it's it's not
free where's the where's the cost
okay here it is here it is apparently he
costs four hundred and ninety seven
dollars he rents a mansion in Bali off
Airbnb and posts it as his own that's
cool oh and by the way all these all
these guys with all their master classes
they're all teaching drop sheets for
dropshipping and affiliate marketing
which are the two biggest nonsense jobs
there are oh here does affiliate
marketing there's a reason that
everybody always talks about them the
only way to actually make them work is
to have a really lucky arbitrage as you
find or to really have a ton of success
like you're already successful and
people know you for it and you have Fame
and so you leverage that Fame to
affiliate market or whatever and that's
the whole thing is like this is the
reason that all these people are making
coaching coaching plans and all this
stuff if they tell you that they're
making a thousand dollars a day or two
thousand dollars a day if that were true
they wouldn't be making these courses I
mean okay let's see the freedom fighter
squad let me guess this guy has a course
oh look massive giveaway oh very cool od
productions who's this Oh passive income
enrollment for a limited time all of us
all of them are limited time they're
using scarcity but they all talk about
launching you with affiliate marketing
and this and that and the question is if
they're so good at creating affiliate
marketing and making thousands of
dollars a day they would just do that
it's clear that all these people care
about is money they all stand next to
you know you know Lamborghinis so if if
all they care about is money why
wouldn't they just make passive income
all the time but of course they're not
making all that money they're trying to
build these separate these separate
businesses and the reason they're trying
to do that is because that's where the
real money is these the grant cardones
of the world the Thai Lopez is they're
not making their money from passive
income or all the way they're saying
they're making money they're making
money from life coaching and this is
what sickens me about this new trend
is the they're profiting off fries that
they're making money they're gonna make
money for you but in all in all honesty
they're just they're they're just
selling you I mean they're selling a
product they're selling inspiration
they're not actually giving you
knowledge because if they had that
knowledge they would do it themselves
it's like I just love is it Graham
Steven hold on they're all the same have
you noticed that they're all the same
it's Ryan
oh here we go Kevin David's life goal oh
there we go there we go
light bulb Kevin David's life goal free
1 million people from the 9 to 5 grind
that's it this guy's this guy's life
goal is to help you do you believe that
this guy all he wants to do is help you
out fire I am ready
well my favorite thing is that all their
intros all look the same it's all like
some you know electronic music over a
supercut of you know Lamborghinis money
them talking but they're not even
looking at the camera and you know
people them in front of a crowd of it
there we go yeah yeah join their
giveaway today click here oh wow yep
yeah let's see let's see if we can go
millionaire by 21 that's the thing it's
like nobody has patience anymore they
want to be life coaches by the time how
I made this how I made how YouTube pays
me for viral video viral videos viral
videos you have 4,000 views of video oh
man
this is hilarious anyways it's just like
so so to answer my original question the
only thing that's worse than Thai Lopez
is a bunch of copycat Tai Lopez's that
have don't even have his his charisma or
none of you call it charisma but even
his just ingenuity just start sort of
what he was doing on the Internet
I mean he really pioneered that that he
pioneered the scam and you gotta respect
him for it but these people are just
disgusting at least he had this you know
at least we got the meme it's not even
that funny even that funny
oh and don't get me started on people
who are telling you how to how to grow a
YouTube channel dad drives me crazy oh
boy anyway for another time for another
time